and then when you talked about Ben what
did you tell me she is my mom she knew
you'd always knew that you would always
get back together because I prayed for
20 years
did Jennifer Lopez's mom Guadalupe have
a hand in her rekindled romance with Ben
Affleck by the way you look beautiful at
the Met Galley what about Lupe how come
Lupe wasn't there
I always put her on TV yeah but can you
blame the Today Show crew for wanting
more of these LOL mother-daughter
moments but
well everyone in studio 1A got a recap
pushing pause on JLo's interview for
this candid confession from the triple
threats mom she knew you'd always knew
that you would always get back together
because I prayed for 20 years
first like this is the interview during
the interview what can I tell you we're
just having a good time of course it's
not the first time we've heard the
prediction that Ben and Jen would find
their way back to each other I've spoken
to her mother Lupe about it like when
Lupe bragged to the Views at Sunny
Hosten after the couple's Vegas nuptials
last summer Lupa has always said that
Ben is her true love and we all have
them and I know that this is going to
last forever and they're going to live
happily ever after and that's why she
took his last name and she loves him
we're trying to get some can you see if
we can get in the papers I'm trying to
get could I could I listen
Okay as Jennifer said let's keep going
over here okay Jan fair enough we'll
keep it moving and instead focus on your
look on the biggest night in fashion by
the way you look beautiful at the Met
galley
that's the triple threat stepping out on
Monday the custom halter gowns courtesy
of Ralph Lauren he also designed her
wedding dress it's just a dream come
true Lupe wasn't at the Met Gala but
seems she's already heard Jen's upcoming
album this is me now then she says this
new album is like nothing we've ever
heard Jennifer do before the same way
this is me then captured a moment in
time a very special moment in time
this album
also did the same thing
[Music]
so fashion check music check movies
another check gen starring in the new
action thriller mother which naturally
got her mama's stamp of approval the
whole conversation is Mercy says you
have to see this movie She's incredible
I'm a killer
but I'm also a mother
you know one of the things my mother
always instilled for me from when I was
very young is that you know girls can
always do whatever you know what I mean
and to be independent and not to ever
depend on anyone for anything 20 plus
years later Lupe proves moms never stop
momming she knew you'd always knew that
you would always get back together
because I prayed for 20 years
[Music]
thank you